Tony please join your cohorts on the
table if you would this is difficult for
me hey I understand we're all friends no
I mean I can't physically I can't get on
the table oh well just use the momentum
of your lower half to hoist yourself up
you know what I'll help I will help
please don't be shy
Dwight let's do this come on we're doing
this thing let's get on three one two
bending the knees okay here we go
here we go I'm under this I'm under this
hock here I don't know what I'm grabbing
here I guess they're just some people
who you stay together with when you
transfer and some people you don't and
that's just the way it is and I can be
mature about that who did this
it's obvious to me I'm not welcome here
but somebody better tell me who did this
or else I'm leaving well I don't think
Aaron seems to like you that's not true
I don't know her enough to make a
decision even what happened what happens
Toby what did you do I think Toby's very
jealous of all the attention you've been
getting no I would never ever do
anything like that but it does seem like
something you would do oh really turn it
on me well isn't that nice thank you
very much Michael appears to be gay too
and yet he is my friend I guess I do
have a gay friend no I'm gonna raise the
stakes you know well you know I want you
to watch this and I want you to burn
this into your brains because this is an
image then I want you people to remember
for a long time to come whenever you
come into the office and want you to
think about this we don't need to yes we
do what
Oh James thanks hunters very talented
you know what I think he's that good
least he's an artist BFD I'm a
screenwriter
I'm a camera maker but you know all you
do is you get me to try to work on my
rich friends for an investment
opportunity man I would love to burn
your handles you burn it you buy it
Oh October and you're our lay by verse
[Music]
dollar plasma screen TV you just count I
have learned a lot about Indian culture
tonight but I have learned even more
about love and I know you're all
thinking who is this crazy gringo and
what is he talking about well I'm not
crazy maybe I'm crazy in love so without
further ado Carol Carol stills I would
like you to do me the honor of making me
your husband
Oh Michael what are you saying
can we talk about this in private I
didn't hear you can we talk about this
in private
okay listen dummy it's not that hard all
you have to do is take the numbers from
the sales report and type them into a
master spreadsheet a JD monkey could do
it I do not understand why you can't do
it no you do not talk to him like that
but he's an idiot hey he's not an idiot
Thank You Holly he is mentally
challenged but he's doing a super job
here wait back up do you think that I'm
[__]
what no joy Oh Holly that is very
offensive I'm sorry all right just
follow my lead and don't pit me all
right come in so uh corporate just said
that I don't want to oh thank you pam
pam can you come in here for a second
let's have a seat I was gonna call you
in anyway um you know Ryan um as you
know there's going to be downsizing and
you have made my life so much easier in
that I am going to have to let you go
first what why why well
theft and stealing stealing um what am I
supposed to have stolen post-it notes
post-it notes
what are those worth like 50 cents 50
cents yeah
you steal a thousand post-it notes at 50
cents apiece and you know you've made up
profit margin you know Carl run us out
of business Pam are you serious yeah oh
I can't believe this I mean I have never
even stolen as much as the paperclip and
now you're firing me but the best thing
about it is that we're not gonna have to
give you any severance pay because that
is gross misconduct and I just clean out
your desk I'm sorry
humanik spoke surprise it's a joke we
were joking around
okay he was in on it he was my
accomplice and that is miss Trudy can't
tell from her costume but she had an
amazing body okay you can and I want you
stop yes that is Edward army ow
yes Chuck Montgomery checking in with
Chet dumpers up I want to be on TV
everybody please shut up please so you
don't miss it okay next
that's me subject in school recess so
tell me what do you want to be when you
grow up I want to be married and have a
hundred kids so I can have a hundred
friends and no one can say no to being
my friend
at least once a year I like to bring in
some of my Kevin's
famous chili the trick is to undercook
the onions everybody is going to get to
know each other in the pot I'm serious
about this stuff I'm up the night before
pressing garlic and dicing whole
Tomatoes I toast my own ancho chiles
it's a recipe passed down from Malone's
for generations it's probably the thing
I do best
mr. Scott I know you're a busy man and
your schedule moves around a lot but for
all your generosity through the years
your tots who are ready to graduate
thought it was time to give you a proper
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
what you gonna do what you gotta do you
came to Eliza made a promise that made
the signers made us realize we don't
need a compromise we're gonna have it
all because you've made it possible for
us to achieve that improbable
[Applause]
you